David packman drinks Bud Light and it
shows before the Dylan Mulvaney thing
when someone like me would say uh Bud
Light is terrible get me a micro brew
get me whatever
the right Wingers would go oh you
drink an American beer drink Bud drink
Coors drink whatever
now those very same people say Bud Light
is the one that's for the sissies who
support the the trans people or whatever
the case may be I have not had a Bud
Light in decades I continue not to drink
Bud Light but it is laughable that that
now counts as an insult but it just
reminds you about the strange bedfellows
and enemies that politics makes when
your brain can be so easily broken